Sony Pictures
we've got some work to do you got some
work to do
[Music]
little Jewish kid vampire know about
this he's half human maybe to give you
some supposed to fly by it this is how
they learn you throw them and they
figure it out I was I can't watch this
please yeah he's still not flying he
will still not either laughing this is a
tall tower wide it's cool I did that my
first time
[Music]
we're gonna need more time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how have I not seen the first one yet I
don't think I even caught like a trailer
of the first one that was [ __ ]
hilarious that really makes me want to
watch the first one dude that looks
really [ __ ] funny I love the
characters of like I feel stupid because
I'm sure you guys already know all this
but the characters of Drac of the Drac
pack and you know Dracula Frankenstein
the Wolfman I've always liked that combo
from way back in the day the first time
I actually ever saw that was Abbott and
Costello Meet Frankenstein but they have
Dracula than that they had the Wolfman
and that I like the Drac pack that's
cool and to see a comedy version of them
is so funny in this animated world it's
witty it's really funny I'm pretty
excited to see this and I saw Adam
Sandler is top billing for it I'm one of
those people who is so aware that Adam
Sandler movies are not good movies but I
still like its personality
Dracula having to take care of a kid
that's pretty [ __ ] funny the kid does
look super Jewish he's a Jewish kid
nothing wrong with that
just wasn't expecting Dracula to do that
or he's an Irish stereotyping people
anyway guys yeah thanks for telling me
to watch that that was well worth it I
can't wait to watch the first one if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects and you
can follow me on Instagram Twitter and
Facebook or fit it would be a good time
for all of us
so ending punchline